[Music]
15 weeks done
two weeks left the saints manhandle the
colts that really wasn't a shocker but
uh what a performance from saints
quarterback
drew brees we talked in the little
two-minute stub on the way in about the
record that has been
broken the latest record actually two
last night two for the price of one if
you watched the game yeah right one
record an all-timer 540 touchdown passes
he finished with 541 beating peyton
manning's record of 539 and single game
completion percentage record by
connecting on 29 of 30 passes a very
memorable night for drew brees in what
could be could be i'm not saying will be
is maybe whatever could have been his
final
regular season home game
in the nfl although based on how he
played last night i would not be packing
it in after this season if i were drew
brees well no i you know that's what
with drew brees tom brady y'all both
look at them and what brees did last
night was amazing but yeah they're
probably sitting there going yeah i'm
getting old but man i can still do some
special things on the field and why
would i want to leave now the team is so
awesome around me too so it's all set up
for success that way but either way drew
brees the accuracy the athleticism still
at 40. you know the ability to make some
blitzer's myths and do that make throws
on the run was all amazing and uh truly
to break the record the way he did would
just it just is kind of the way they've
always done in sean payton drew brees
just obliteration dissection accuracy uh
you know a blitz of formations and
personnels and oh yeah we're going to
throw it to michael thomas but it
doesn't really matter that you know it
we're just going to keep throwing it to
him and he'll have a bunch of catches i
just spoke to everything the saints and
drew brees have been through this era
and it was uh even though it was a
blowout it was kind of fun to watch
because i kept going man i mean keep
throwing it let's see if he can go 39
for 40. let's keep it going it was it
was uh it was truly great greatness at
its best
he said after the game that he'll be
haunted by the one that he didn't
connect on but 29-30 still pretty darn
good and he's got 22 straight
completions he only needs like four more
to set the all-time record for
consecutive completions across multiple
games we'll see whether he can do that
on sunday against the tennessee titans
let me ask you this chris yeah because
there's a bunch of quarterbacks
currently due to be free agents in march
including brees and brady
of the two right if both were ready to
play next year of the two which one
would you want heading into 2020. oh my
gosh that's a really
great question um
uh you know okay i would say this they
both have
when i look at them and i just see their
flaws right they're still really good
they both of course can win you a super
bowl the way they're playing right now i
would say if there's a flaw to tom brady
a little bit of the jumpiness in the
pocket at times right right and rightly
so the protection's not been good if
there's a flaw to uh to drew brees it's
his ability to be explosive in the
passing game you know and push push the
ball down the field and really get the
top tier defenses to back off and that's
the thing i maybe i worry about with the
saints going forward but i think i would
probably still take brady it's really
close but i think i would take brady
just um yes i just think the way brady
still
his size his ability to still throw
rockets all over the field and all that
uh i would i would i would lean on him
just a little bit more than drew brees i
think he opens up the field a little bit
more than brees does
i would have said that before last night
but watching that game last night and i
don't know if it was the confluence of
you know the record he was about to set
the 10-year anniversary right of the
super bowl 44 championship all of his
old teammates there emphasis on old when
we saw the shots of some of the guys on
the sideline then you realize the guy
who was the quarterback that team is
still playing so maybe he was just
feeling spry last night grandma are you
spry maybe he was feeling spry
but
it occurred to me the way i saw him
dodging the blitzer on that one player
where he just kind of squirted out i i
said
hey drew brees is playing better than
tom brady right now i think i'd want to
see what happens the rest of the way
before i make my budgetary decisions for
2020 about which quarterback i want to
pursue but i feel a lot better about
drew brees now than i do right now yeah
i do about tom brady yeah well i hear
you i mean i get it and like i said it
is close i do think like to your point
with brees his mobility and ability to
dodge people is probably better than
brady's at this point now you know the
other thing too we got to take into
account just the support around him you
know he's arguably got the best receiver
in football you know he's definitely
behind one of the one or two three best
offensive lines in football he's got
taysom hill he's got a really good tight
end of course a great play caller so i
think all those and then yes i mean it's
easy not to fall or it's easy to fall
into the trap last night which was just
dissection i mean come on you know it
was like the perfect storm the saints
were on fire the cults were kind of like
and the colts you know to speak about
them for a second they just got no
difference makers they got you know what
what on their team is their stand on
right now to go oh that's the guy that's
gonna make a play ooh that's the
superstar on the defense who's the best
player on their defense who's another
guy named not named darius leonard that
sticks out to you in the colts so i
think it was all just a perfect storm
and then just how many times do you see
sean payton create match-ups to where
you go well there's a safety covering
the best receiver in football for the
third time this half how does that
happen i don't know
but that's just the greatness of both of
them and i hear you though mike it's
close it's very close
the record too the
passing touchdown number 540 that was a
sean payton play that wasn't a drew
brees play no john designed a play that
sprung josh hill wide open easy throw
you or i could have made it even i could
have made it to get number 540 although
it's number one through 539 i would have
had a problem with it
and here's part of it too here's another
part of it too because sean payton was
asked what that record means after the
game and he said
it
what what what means a lot is winning
we're trying to win here it's not about
the records we'll all ride off into the
sunset at some point and that'll be nice
then and he also pointed out something
very important this is going to be a
fluid record now i don't know that it's
going to be back and forth because i
think drew brees is going to
re-establish a gap i agree a gap that he
had before he missed five games right
earlier this year with that thumb injury
but the reality is whichever of the two
guys between brees and brady plays that
extra year yeah in comparison to the
other guy that's the guy who's getting
up with the record it definitely seems
that way i mean i think we're gonna go
into this off season
you know definitely with brees having
the record you know the way their
offense is playing and rolling i would
con figure he continues to put up pretty
good stats here the last two weeks of
the season where hey brady you know
again yes they won 30 brady brady ain't
throwing five against the bills on
saturday there's no way exactly right
there's no way well i mean even the way
the game winning in cincinnati what was
the final score the other day 34-13 is
am i right about that 34-10 whatever it
was and you know we sat there together
and watched the games it was
strugglesville for that offense it
wasn't pretty the defense set them up a
lot so i think the saints and where drew
brees are at on that side of the ball
leaves them certainly in a more
comfortable position to kind of explode
these next two weeks offensively as
compared to brady and the pats
yeah and look the saints the the big
news is they win and they're in that
cluster of teams in the nfc four teams
at 11 and three one of those teams is
gonna be 13 and three and be the one
seed crazy you know we could there's all
sorts of different permutations and
obviously between the 49ers and the
seahawks only one of those three or one
of those two is going to win one of the
three divisions that will have an 11 and
three or better champion right now based
upon where things currently stand but i
look the same the saints end up with the
one seed
yeah it's tough you know
yeah right and hey the seahawks come to
town the 49ers come to town the packers
comes i think the packers the one team
that stands out to me of the four teams
that are eleven and three that doesn't
feel like it belongs but that may work
to their advantage in the playoffs
because teams may overlook them and just
think oh this is a neat look what
happened to them against the 49ers it's
gonna be easy i'd be very leery of the
packers when we get to that final four
in the nfc if those four eleven and
three teams as of right now are left
i don't disagree for two reasons with
your thought on the packers because i
i'm with you mike all the way on that i
think they're the lesser of the four
teams but as far as playoffs are
concerned they have three things i like
they have a running back and a running
game that's good not great they have
number 12 at quarterback and we know
what he can do in certain situations or
big games or anything like that with
rogers and then the other thing i like
about them just as far as playoff
football mike pettin is an outside the
box thinker on the defensive side of the
ball as a defensive coordinator he'll do
some stuff that defenses are just not
going to be ready for in a playoff
scenario too so there'll be some game
plan specific stuff he'll throw out of
teams that's going to be a curveball
he's not afraid to take a chance or take
this guy away or do something somewhat
absurd as far as x's and o's uh to where
yeah they're dangerous i just don't know
if the qual i still look at it like you
know i i don't know how you are i look
at it still as the saints and the 49ers
are
are a notch above then the seahawks who
are then a notch just above then the
packers in that top four
i don't disagree with that but the 49ers
are going to have to win in seattle yeah
they are avoid having to play in the
wild card rounds so the best team in the
nfc may have the most difficult path of
any of those teams that are currently
11-3 but look the saints had the one
seed last year and it ultimately didn't
work out due in part to that horrific
non-call of pass interference but yeah
i'm so impressed by the saints ability
to reset this year yeah to forget about
what happened last year to forget about
what happened against minnesota the year
before that and what happened
this year after the bye week right they
just we kind of thought they went
through a lull this season and they kind
of took off from there again too
and 30 47 last night we were talking
about this yesterday the saints really
hadn't blown anybody out in a while
right right they haven't they they've
been they've been screwing around with
inferior opponents when they get one of
those games and now they they have the
colts walk in the colts were still alive
last night they weren't done they were
done they're done that's into the game
they're done now yeah uh so no do you we
can leave them out of all the
permutations in the afc that makes life
a little bit easier but look it was a
huge win for the saints and a great
night for drew brees and it just makes
me wonder watching him last night
because i thought i would have gone into
last night thinking there's a good
chance this is his last year he doesn't
talk about it
he doesn't have an expiration date and
and i think that makes it possible even
more possible that any given year will
be the last year but my gosh what i saw
last night i hope he keeps playing i i
hope that we see more drew brees next
year maybe even the year after he's not
even 41 yet tom brady's doing it at 42
right and brees has kept himself in
great shape he's highly competitive if
he stays with sean payton i think he can
keep doing a lot of things that we've
seen over the last 14 years yeah i'm
with you mike
and when you play like that and having a
season that they're having and he's
having yeah i just hard to walk away as
a competitor to go you know no matter
what happens this year whether they win
the super bowl or lose the divisional
playoff game it doesn't matter he's
going to walk off the field this year
ago and we're going to have a chance to
do this again next year with the way
their team set up i mean they got
everything you need to kind of be very
relevant here for the next few years or
at least the recent recent future and i
just think for that it'll be hard for
him to walk away as well
and the other side of it is this too i
mean i think he's going to be successful
in anything he does after playing
football but there aren't a lot of jobs
they're going to pay him 25 million or
more per year so squeeze out one more
year of that or two or three if you can
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports